[Music]
[Music]
from a terrorist perspective if you want
to organize an attack it makes perfect
sense to organize it from Belgium
there's a very thin line between
criminals and terrorists in Belgium
the Belgian authorities were not
prepared they thought it wasn't possible
here
[Music]
[Music]
Brussels has long been a breeding ground
for terrorism now it has become a victim
of it the remnants of a cell that
brought terror to Paris had been at
large here for months before they struck
again at home
but why has this happen to Brussels how
has the e used political capital also
become a center for terror
and there's another question why
couldn't they stop this happening they
knew there was a threat to this city but
they weren't able to protect themselves
check there supposing I kiss you see
deep I don't know how funky they applica
doses at dota Veronique son Sammy is a
jihadist it's a check for key and even
mark himself the police and swap
amorphous his wallet they're here
ask Sam I support Arab Lee did the Delhi
trade
Daisy no sir only total male victim
likely family David limited sir Baskar
on a German modica news office wopatina
ba it scoliosis a canoe or Lully that
kidnapping knows of only Veronique lives
in Muhlenberg a borough of 90,000 people
80% Muslim suspected Paris attacker
Salah abdel-salam grew up here
and as Europe's most wanted man avoided
detection in this community for four
months before being arrested on the 18th
of March some claim it is a virtual
no-go area where the police have lost
their grip it's shocking and it's only
possible of course if there are enough
people who protect him and who hide him
and who feel more solidarity with that
criminal than with the society they are
living in and the devastating idea is
also beyond all this is that those
people who were protecting the criminals
a terrorist or most of the time people
born in Belgium who went to Belgium
schools who were in theory part of
Virgin Society says oh dear on TV Tony
Cottee a certain key to the Karthik so
definitely the ketubah could difficulty
monogamy certainty for la politique una
valoración de Bru's el nopal NSSF poor
Don le même chose a treatment session
lucky de Kirchner college teacher may
follow the truth the truth bamboo lo que
vive la monstrosity susan la susato
certain Muhlenberg has been linked to a
chilling number of terrorist atrocities
even with 9/11 in New York there was a
link with with Brussels the attack in
London there was a link with Brussels in
Madrid there was a link in Brussels
police of course you know it very well
there was a link with Brussels
Madrid bomb plotter hassan al husky
spent time in rolling back amedy
coulibaly who killed four people in a
Paris kosher grocery store got the guns
in Merlin Beck and a number of the
November Paris attackers were born in
moaning Bell the entrance to Malin Beck
tube station right now is a military
checkpoint this district is considered
an incubator for terrorism the place of
jihadi hideouts where too many men born
European have grown up to hate
everything it stands for Belgium has per
head of population become the largest
contributor to Islamic state in Europe
450 Belgium Muslims have traveled out to
Syria and Iraq including 23 year old
Sammy veronik son seen in this is
propaganda video wearing a headscarf
vamos a ver guitar scares I got sick
over t al Islam I know the Catholic
religion decart is attitudinal more evil
a purely allegories catalytic Paskus
nouvion often quoted and often visible
t-tapp t he said the pre-service
criteria the new event was vocally but
the Turkish was I won't talk to you to
say a bill a particular heated mm I saw
Bertie secure a family no revenue
[Music]
Olivia's son was killed fighting jihad
in Syria but Sean's journey to
radicalization started with a desire to
help homeless people
it was doing charity in Brussels when my
son turned to me I go to give food to
the poor people I say wonderful is great
you're generous it was organized by a
belch convert by Islam he he ridiculous
the young by doing these activities what
we've noticed in Belgium like in many
other countries these past few years is
that they don't recruit in mosques
anymore
they recruits in youth organization they
recruit on the street they recruit on
the neighborhood and then after that you
have this kind of snowball effect one
individual gets into the movement he
talks to his brother to his cousin to
his good friend and they get radicalized
themselves and so that is why you have
very solid very coherent groups at this
time this generation of young in
Brussels have no hope for the future
because of this there are quite easy
influence and also they want to change
the world but they are telling these
young people is you are living in a belt
in society but this is a society that
rejects you you have you are a second
hand citizen and if you really want to
be a real citizen convert to the Islam
and you'll be a true citizen you'll find
peace with yourself and you will be
accepted so why are young people
particularly receptive to that message
in moaning back
it is a socially deprived area but you
could say that at hundreds of districts
across Europe that said divides here are
stark take unemployment among
second-generation Moroccan men it's at
forty one percent compared to
belgian-born men at four percent say any
potato envy aidez national me who said
you said the Johnson poof
yeah buku do so much done it's totally
show message and get a strophic yeah but
this war the man responsible for
dressing this problem for 20 years was
the former mayor of Merlin Beck Philip
Moore oh I've ever say that
ghettoization we we know our target to
mess up or talk at all certain villain
LASIK the on certain city the laborious
Parisian marriages is it you need so if
he not see Alex let the public the
project yam net in no you know popular
song proved classe moyenne pre-classic
at the end of his mare ship in 2012 he
wrote a book defending his time at the
helm he doesn't blame ghettoization so
much as the growth of a criminal element
with in Muhlenberg so key characteristic
a Moranbah cake yeah effective Minelli
motoblur sexy la cosa que hay una
persona about
in saloon criminal particular mo I
popped on TV alone say elope when deeper
me about a topic sonar Chicano DeSoto it
a personage get a peruzzo Reza Khan
television Renata cadaver or silly akia
racy a traverses ancien connoisseur see
comedy connoisseurs who know to update
the copper actually a metal
it's a noona viola abdel hamid a diode
referred to by mr. Momo was the
mastermind of the Paris attacks in the
Islamic state magazine he bragged of his
ability to come and go between Syria
Brussels and Paris a convicted armed
robber he wasn't the only jihadist with
criminal connections khalid el bakraoui
who blew himself up on the metro and his
brother ibrahim one of the airport
bombers were also carjackers and bank
robbers before upscaling
to terrorism the two of the suicide
attackers had these connections to the
serious crimes they were convicted of
Kalashnikov type of criminal activities
before now if these gangsters can turn
into jihadists we are into a real
serious problem what we're seeing is
that there's a very thin line between
criminals and terrorists Belgium all
known terrorists have a criminal records
you know when you are a gangster you
have been a gangster all your life you
have acquired skills and acquired an
attitude like el bakraoui brain Roca had
already shot on the police with
Kalashnikov as a criminal so you know
you are already there so you know this
is also an element that makes this group
quite interesting for for initialization
and also make make good terrorists out
of them and fast
to understand how the people plotting
this atrocity went undetected you need
to look closer at these radicalized
cells and their links to violent crime
which it turns out is something the
authorities failed to do Friday prayers
in Brussels central mosque four days
after the attacks the large proportion
of Muslim immigrants to Belgium are
Turkish or Moroccan but the money for
this mosque came from Saudi Arabia since
the 70s
Saudi influence in Belgium has been
growing and Saudi Arabia was granted the
position of leadership in Belgium Islam
there's a group of people who converted
to salafism or Wahhabism and you know
the problem with Wahhabism is that if
you convert to that it is a very law be
diems ideology on the other hand if you
make just a little ideological switch
we're changing just one ruling saying
that you can go fight you the ruler you
don't have to obey the ruler then you
become a jihadi Salafist after prayers a
minute's silence is held in memory of
the victims
not a massager say Nero's intellectual
demon the software doctor to give our
oppressor Keyshia pass a set even more
catastrophic he some commie bastard a
the swarms in monkey kipapa la acción
another islam Dzongkha saladna party
that islam this lambda chi knowledge on
the pay season last verse of the effects
economy from the verse a sank the last
what enough a year to alaykum battle-ax
cetera well it O'Keefe Oakley in an
affirmative logic concerns lap of a
speak Asian la casilla Vexilar no Vienna
valve I think love ambition and of
instrumentally the shortest attacks but
over the last decade two key groups have
been responsible for twisting a message
or days versus one is called
sharia4belgium this is the group's
leader
Fouad focus on people who never took
them seriously they were just people
laughed at them but intelligent services
already done warned off don't get fooled
by these people they are actively
recruiting
among young people in the streets was
extremely successful here in Belgium in
recruiting and radicalizing young
individuals that movement I was first
base in Antwerp and then that sort of
had a branch here in Brussels that
worked pretty well and as far as we know
has been responsible for sending about
80 individuals to Serie A t-80
the man who wanted to destroy the
atonium is now in prison along with
radical preacher Khalid zu Carney who
ran a separate group but many of their
converts went to Syria their associates
include Najam la Crowley Paris bomb
maker and thought to be one of the
suicide bombers who struck Brussels
Airport we have left perhaps too much
space for some of these individuals some
of these organizations on the principle
perhaps of freedom of expression you
know where does that where does that
stop shaker no mado de una una casa el
Cucuy the jihadism Pascal model on hope
to move at a fo chasse Bashar al Assad
avec la pequeña is sasaki no se camino
de papinek maman is big there was also
controversy in Belgium over the
treatment of jihadists when they came
back figures released last month show
117 foreign fighters have returned to
Belgium one of them Miquel Yoon was
sentenced to just six months for his
involvement with the terrorist group the
first thing that struck me is that
people who fought in Syria could get off
with three months six months sentences
and they are back you know walking
freely
but many weren't picked up at all
Airport bomber ibrahim el-bakraoui
according to turkish authorities was
sent back from the syrian border last
year with a warning that he was an is
fanatic he had also breached parole by
going to Turkey but wasn't arrested on
his return at least in Belgium that
should have rung a bell saying this is a
criminal convicted in Belgium to nine
years of imprisonment who was released
on parole what is he doing in Turkey
near the Turkish border there is there's
a little bit less than a thousand
individuals that are suspected of being
related to the Islamic state one way or
the other and there is about a thousand
people in the intelligence services or
Federal Police that are in charge of
monitoring them so it's a ratio one on
one that makes the job very very
complicated ibrahim el-bakraoui
and his brother khalid were able to
vanish into the jihadi criminal
underworld of Brussels
but these networks didn't just help them
hide what terrorist wants are assault
rifles who can do a lot of damage in a
very short timeframe and Kalashnikovs
types of weapons are very well suited to
do exactly that now what we've noticed
in in recent years is the increased
availability of exactly those types of
weapons on to the criminal market and
it's getting easier for criminals to get
their hands on these guns which means
it's also easier for terrorists who are
exactly the ones wanting these weapons
to actually acquire them on the criminal
market Brussels policing is high
visibility especially now but critics
say Belgian police haven't got a grip on
terrorism and gun trafficking because
they're too fragmented with Brussels for
example having six forces controlled by
different mayors and a federal layer of
police above that brothers they had been
spotted by local police more than a year
ago before the left for Syria and
apparently that intelligence that
information was then transmitted to the
federal police because in Belgium we
have this difference between local and
federal police and somehow I they'd get
lost it wasn't find properly and the
former chief of police for skarbek
believes Federal Police are trying to
run terror investigations without using
the community contacts of local police
they had to be emit people because there
you can have really good information
exact information and we really
controlled the the commune here we know
a lot over the commune and when I heard
after the attacks in Paris that Salah
Abdeslam was proud to Brussels first in
the commune of flaggin and then here to
skarbek my reflection was immediately OH
if it had been in my time with the team
we had we had him we catch them sure one
of the problems that we have is good
data registration
we don't know how many guns are being
seized in Belgium for example we don't
know that which means we also don't know
the context in which they are being
seized so they're not storing the data
on the seizing of weapons often there is
data storage but it's on paper and as
long as it's on paper it's very
difficult to analyze
so Belgium has a highly marginalized
Islamic community some criminally
connected radicals with access to a new
supply of weapons in addition to the
bomb training and brutalization that
they acquire and trips to Syria and yet
there seemed to be a complacency among
some that Belgium wouldn't be a target I
think that Belgian government always
thought that if they let terrorists
quiet here in Belgium that they won't
have problems I think that the
government wanted to be quite no
terrorist attacks here in Belgium you
may be safe here quite but don't attack
here in Belgium they're actively sending
out that message yeah I think so yeah in
recent weeks authorities also might have
thought that they had neutralized the
threat alleged terrorists mohamed
belkaid was killed during a police raid
on a suspected safehouse in forest the
rest of Salah Abdeslam just days before
the attacks was another victory but
these events probably was when he was
arrested was interviewed or interrogated
just for one hour and two days
afterwards we had the attacks then I
become angry because I I am convinced
that they could have maybe took off took
out information out of him because you
know like it could have been my my
children in the Metro you know it's the
same line we take everything
it was very worrying that once they
raided the house with all the weapons in
it they also found two detonators and
you know exactly what that means it
means that there are some explosives out
there they were very close they even had
salah of islam the most wanted terrorist
in europe and nevertheless three days
later four days later these attacks
occurred so maybe there I believe this
country went in five days from complete
euphoria to complete the feat that's
definite and that's the fate of Belgium
on the one hand the intelligence
services are playing catch-up but so to
society he's also a bird a Brazilian
they saw the pass casino of a certain
party in new version Arizona Caribbean
iki faces at ulta so Patterson phone
late Islamic extremist in deeper
fabricate the most fabricate the most
havoc no cell phone